[Music]
okay Jenny and I are back at it again
we're at AMC which got done see into the
new Suspiria it's taking place in the
1970s in Germany a bunch of witches
running a coven out of a dance studio a
bunch of weird [ __ ] happens the first
for me I think the first act because
it's broken up and a bunch of acts the
first act was kind of boring and
nonsensical it seemed to be at the time
I was kind of swimming I saw one guy get
up and leave he never came back but by
the time the end - act - and maybe began
at act 3 I started to pick up I actually
liked it it ended up being really good I
did see two women get up and leave I
think in the third act they never came
back I don't know what the problem was
it is I just got to say it is a
pretentious kind of an art flick the way
it starts it's very European it's not
really done in an American style I
wouldn't even really say an Italian
style it seemed very bland and boring at
first it got pretty colorful and some
weird [ __ ] happened in it I we can't do
any spoilers
I'd recommend I'd recommend the movie
just don't expect a Hollywood style
movie all right it's it's a [ __ ] trip
other than that I liked it what'd you
think Jenny really oh I tell you what
man I hated the first maybe 20 minutes
in the movie I'm like man this [ __ ]
[ __ ] about halfway through it is like
madness this is kind of a weird
perverted masterpiece and then it kind
of built up into this big [ __ ] thing
I was a man this is weird [ __ ]
okay so I'm I'm imagining that most
people that are gonna go see this movie
are familiar with the original obviously
yeah see I've never seen it so I'm just
like I even know what the movies about
okay so I want to say that when I first
heard that they were remaking this I was
really pissed up some like how can you
remake Suspiria it's a classic and stuff
but actually I have to say I'm really
glad the movie it pretty much just took
the bare-bones story of the original you
know American dancer or Suzy Banyan she
goes to Germany to a dance academy you
know just like the original movie a lot
of the characters are the same and stuff
like character names and things like
that you know the teachers names are the
same but other than that they went in a
kind of a different direction with it
which i think was a really good idea
other than doing like Dario Argento's
thing where everything was very operatic
and very like brightly colored and like
everything was very baroque they kind of
went the opposite way with it they said
it was like very dingy very grey yeah
it's just like hints of color also I
liked that they added a lot of backstory
for Suzy Banyan they added a lot of
backstory for the cumin like you got to
know what was going on like was it
coming and everything they actually
added a really interesting like
political element like what was going on
in Berlin yeah yeah I don't want to get
into that too much a lot of this love is
[ __ ] she's talking about as a first-time
viewer or not not really know anything
about story I don't know if I was
misunderstanding it or reading into it
it's kind of a convoluted story it's
kind of confusing I thought maybe that
my interpretation was is that the wick
the witches actually brought the Third
Reich into being and I like that I like
that it kind of like deep in the story
someone like I said just because they
kind of they had a different
screenwriter on this but they had like
the original script by it you know
yeah obviously but they just like I said
took the barebone story and they added
like a lot more elements to it so you
got to see it wasn't quite as
claustrophobic I mean the original it
was pretty much the entire thing to set
in the dance academy was just a couple
of scenes elsewhere this one kind of
like expanded the universe out there
were some flashbacks that were like some
you know some other stuff so you got to
kind of see the the past of some of the
characters and what was going on and
like I said added that political element
that was going on in Germany and divided
Berlin and then 70s which I thought was
kind of a cool concept that they kind of
had a parallel is going on with that and
with some like dissension and the coven
and stuff also gotta say I'm not gonna
spoil it really differrent ending yeah
like I said I didn't know I didn't even
know what kind of movie this was I
didn't ask her anything I didn't know
anything to do with witches that first
20 30 minutes was pretty [ __ ] painful
if you don't know what you what's in
store you have to be patient you have to
let this movie unfold and once it does
it's pretty [ __ ] weird yeah and and
I'm not sure I totally understand
everything that would happen
I'd prior to see it again I don't know
its to nap hours long I don't know if
I'd sit through it again you that's the
only thing I this is you know there are
a lot of elements of this kind of
reminded me of The Shining to do where
you just you're not really sure what's
going on yeah it does yeah but other
than that we really can't really say
much about our
Suspiria makes a yeah it's good it's a
pretty good flick you know I mean but
like I said be patient with it it's very
yeah very pretentious and it takes a
while for it to get
you
okay so we just got done seeing bugging
me in Rhapsody that's got to tell you
that's [ __ ] awesome this is a really
good movie boy I tell you what the
acting was fantastic I mean he got he
had for Freddie Mercury down yeah that
was like when I was watching movie like
I forgot yeah I think yeah you you
forget especially especially during like
his on stage performances his blocking
and all the moves that the furni mercury
did on stage and he just [ __ ] perfect
but it goes throughout the entire
history of the band Freddie Mercury's
come like this family background also
like what his relationship was like with
his first wife and girlfriend and then
the whole thing about you know [ __ ]
kind of like his relationship with guys
take kind of took over his life and just
but he really couldn't get away from his
first wife either he was really in love
with his wife yeah but yeah a really
good movie and one thing I didn't notice
is that it did because we lived through
a lot of that we were at least little
kids I said well the live in it I saw
that baby in 85 I was 13 years old they
perfectly captured the the feelings of
the time that that's what it was like
yeah and if you're a younger person
you're into like 70's and 80's culture
and what the music was like then you got
to see this movie yes that's the way
people work I mean it's like you know it
follows the same thing it's like a lot
of like you know music biopics but I
have to say that I really I love music
biopics and especially ones about like I
love like velvet goldmine and all its
kind of stuff I especially loved ones
about fabulous freaks yeah I mean like
people that are like misfits and then
destroy a band so there is a fantastic
and it's like everybody finally has to
like acknowledge how many become a
champion and then their brain it's like
and it's just I [ __ ] love that
and this whole thing was just like the
total embodiment of that yeah and I'm
just like yeah it's just fantastic and I
love the guy that played it and it's you
know because we really like mercury I
predict I predict that this movie will
do very well it's a very feel-good movie
I mean even though everybody knows like
how it ends but I like that they didn't
really dwell on that I'm not because
everybody knows you know what yeah we're
Freddy Freddy achieved what he liked and
that like is that fits in with his
character that's way it was he was a
self-made you know he basically changed
his name he changed his whole background
it's like he kind of invented I had no
idea that he was Indian
yeah I thought it was just random white
guy yeah but yes that yeah that was
interesting like how they when he was
first starting out like yeah yeah it's
kind of like Oh Britain in the 70s yeah
yeah I also like I like the fact that
because of the times none of it fits
into the to this eras kind of stereotype
gender identity politics they didn't
play that back then there was no rule
books there was just break all the rules
well yeah there wasn't that it wasn't a
rules there wasn't a way to be gay they
knew that was just like you know it
obviously it's not new but it was
something that you know was kind of
coming into at least the counterculture
yeah it was for people who weren't in
the same people who weren't in it but
they didn't matter nobody cared about
that it's it's a feel-good movie like
yeah it's um I wouldn't mind seeing it
again actually yeah and the sound is
fantastic you want to see high quality
version it's not this
one day after a lot of people in there I
also predict there will be an uptick in
Queen albums so I'm sure because I
actually assist yeah I forgot how cool
that song was thinking that I was like I
want to buy that out yeah but uh
definitely this is gonna be a good movie
I don't this is probably one of the top
movies of the month I'm gay yeah so I'm
glad that it was you know everything
explained was actually better than that
yeah it's good yeah
All Right see you around guys
okay Jenny and I just got out from
seeing what with the Nutcracker yeah
Nutcracker for elves but I had had
trouble getting through this one it was
I was not the intended it's kind of
interesting it's like obviously based on
the ballet a bit also based on the short
story the Mouse King there was okay it
was like super super beautiful to look
at yeah it had like it had some really
cool sequences like when they first got
in the fourth realm which is like this
creepy like abandoned amusement park
yeah and I have to say the outfit that
whether ginger was wearing it then who
was played by Helen Mirren but
ultimately like it kept my attention
like the story was kind of cool but it's
like I don't know it said there was
something very Hollow oh yeah I was
getting ready to say that you know Jenny
and I kind of maybe we have a unique
perspective you know Disney is a is a
local industry it's a local company yes
pretty much all of our friends at one
time or another have worked for Disney
or still work for Disney and yes
Disney has a certain corporate
philosophy and the way that it makes
products everything they do is very
planned over processed to modernize
pasteurized it's gone through many many
different committees to see if
everything checks out and it just ends
up being very kind of shallow and
soulless very nothing spontaneous
got it it was like I said it was really
beautiful the costumes are beautiful the
sets were beautiful but like I said I
just couldn't get it it's like watching
a commercial I couldn't get a handle on
like the characters I couldn't really
you know the fantasy yeah but it's like
everybody just I don't know everybody
said the acting was fine it was just
fantasy is not reality and they sell
fantasy so everything is very very
unreal unnatural artificial and in some
ways man it kind of [ __ ] tacky it's
that it's very American with a fake
veneer of European culture a lot of this
[ __ ] seems to be you can't tell this is
Victorian London is this Victorian
Russia but it's like a parallel universe
Russia where everybody takes showers and
there's lots lots of diversity and you
know it just kind of takes away from
realism but I understand what they're
doing that might be a good call because
fantasy is not realism
the way it is this is a movie you take
your little daughter to go see and they
trip out over the princess fantasies and
[ __ ] that's really all this is there's
really nothing to this movie yeah like I
said it wasn't I don't know it's there
was just something about it it just
didn't sit like it didn't really like I
said it just really grabbed me it's like
like I said it was pretty to look at but
it's just cheap holo artificial in tacky
really good yeah it's and it's because
it's soulless yeah very very good
but I did see on like rotten tomatoes
and stuff like that this is getting very
mad yeah well they don't think Disney
can't take any risks it just does it
just formula very very formula yeah and
everything they touch kind of loses any
kind of unique personality like I said I
feel like tween girls uh probably love
this
you know to me I had a hard time staying
awake I had a hard time sitting through
it I was like this [ __ ] sucks you know
and I'm not the intended audience you
don't I mean this is for tween girls you
know and as an adult male I just have to
take a deep breath and just well I
wanted to go to sleep I just life it's
there look at my hair [ __ ] up my hair
to say that sleep here come my hair's
like this is like I was just lucky with
Sun we saw it Dolby with that big fat
people chairs we heard you can get the
musical score was actually pretty decent
I mean there was a lot of good things
about it it's just that it's hard yes
it's like it aspects of it like the
ballet portions were really cool it's
like the acting was good it was just
something didn't it's because together
just it's good because they're trying to
sell a fantasy realm but they have to
sell this fantasy realm this fantasy
experience and it can't really offend
anyone so they go over and over it and
they tweak it and tweak it and it's so
pasteurized and it's gone through so
many committees that there's absolutely
no spontaneity I'm not sure I haven't
read the short story that it's based on
yeah yeah well they were trying to do
that detective they're doing some ripoff
so that guy here's another thing though
that was weird
there was sexual innuendo in this there
was for us here's the thing you know
every Disney movie I've seen always had
some underlying sexual innuendos about
like strong hard men and their weapons
and then the girl that was sent in a
quiver up her spine and there was some
weird daddy issues with the girl is well
like I said there's it was kind of I've
always been like you know maybe this
goes back to like a more innocent time
and like I said the the part that was in
they quote unquote real or post was real
world was must be like Victorian England
or whatever I've always been kind of
freaked out by like father-daughter
dances so I know they still do them
nowadays but that's always been really
creepy to me and I think you're wearing
you're wearing your mother's some people
maybe we're just perverts and that's our
problem with it's like well they didn't
really but they did throw some in UN -
and this may be really know that
Disney's filled with [ __ ] freak
freakazoid people that worked there so
like I said I don't know how much of
that was I'm the source of this here you
are
but some of that did make me go okay
well they're just done with the daddy
issue things yeah but yeah so you know
like I said if you have twin girls they
probably love the [ __ ] yeah
see this it's like it was it was alright
but you know I didn't I couldn't get
into it I just thought it was tagged
that's better it was a tacky overdone
soulless corporate [ __ ]
[Music]